announcement there are no planned fire
drills so if the alarm activates please
leave the building in an orderly fashion
via your nearest fire exit please use
either the fire exit through the main
doors of the hall or the fire exit to
the store room adjacent to the stage the
fire assembly point is the island in
front of the main entrance to the
building please do not delay your
evacuation to collect any belongings
please do not return to the building
until given permission to do so by
Council staff please note that me me
that this meeting will be live streamed
please switch off mobiles or turn them
to
silent so that's my laptop toilets and
handwashing facilities are available in
the foyer
area think um agenda item one apologies
for absence members we have received
apologies from councelor James Gooding
councelor Simon won councelor Ian Ward
councelor Mrs Christine Mason and
councelor Gary
Meyers are there any other apologies
represents please
sorry nobody is
indicating um agenda item two substitute
members uh councelor Ian Foster for
councel Ian Ward and councelor Daniel FY
for councelor Simon w
agenda item three nonmembers attending
there are
none agenda item four minutes of the
meeting held on the 13th of September
2023 um now I have got one note and then
I'll ask uh members if they they've got
any comments or um notes um if we can
refer to page seven please of uh the
minutes the second paragraph from last
um
regarding the um acur saving um from the
parks for nature um this was queried by
councelor uh Mrs Mason um officers have
responded that any savings were
redistributed within the same service
area so I just want to make sure that
that is included within the minutes
going forward so that's in relation to
that saving that was noted there um is
uh members happy with
that lovely um any other comments or
questions on the minutes are they agreed
then
members thank
you agenda item five to rec uh receive
Declarations of Interest are there any
members nobody's indicating thank
you gender item six the one team
transformation program our strategic
partnership with brenwood Bar Council
Quarter Two update I will now invite
Greg Campbell the council's director of
policy and delivery to introduce the
report thank you chair good evening
members um just update it the report is
fairly comprehensive in front of you um
good news is this is quarter two of the
second year work is continuing on the
service reviews and going through at the
moment you will see risk management and
insurance emergency planning business
continuity procurement customer contact
and economic development and inward
investment so they've all gone through
the process and they're heading towards
consultation stage we're also working on
Finance and Accounting parking uh
planning policy uh and corporate
services and a number of others will
come in through the next couple of
months and we're on schedule to complete
all service reviews in time by around
April 202 for next year of that phase
and everything else the communications
team are well embedded now and so are
the HR and they've employed to all the
positions so they're fully compliment of
what they should be doing happy to take
any questions or if there's any further
updates someone
once thank you Greg um councelor FD
thank you chairman three questions
probably quite quick uh there's an
unpend
56450 is in that in line with what
you're
thinking
um it's unspent at the moment I'm hoping
that what we're looking at is how we
phase it out over the next few months in
what we need to spend don't want to
spend it unnecessarily of course but
there are some a number of service
reviews coming up where we may need to
put some resources to it and support the
staff that are going through it as well
yeah and and another question it's
always interesting to see how morale is
on this so 3.22 in the report as catches
performance and development career
conversations to be reviewed appraised
across both organizations Capt part
captured as part of oneu conversations
is that is that any way that could be
anonymously give some information back
to council members we can see a broad
overview of how the staff are doing with
morale and stuff like that yeah so the
oneu conversations are kind of um our
new appraisal process which is where we
put them the staff at the heart of the
conversation we ask how they're feeling
how they're getting on what training
needs how we support them and making
sure that they're achieving the targets
uh within the council that we want them
to achieve um in terms of feedback on
morale I can look at how we do that um
we are looking always at kind what we
call Pulse surveys where we ask kind of
the I was going to say residents where
we ask the staff how they're feeling
what what it's like and we can report
that back in the future so that's one
way we can do it for you members if you
want that included it's not in the next
quarter it may be the one after that I'd
have to check with HR when we're doing
that next poll survey what a can sorry
you right sorry well can so we recently
had a staff briefing uh where we took a
number of questions and I would say it
depends where staff are on the spectrum
of service reviews and sometimes how
they're feeling okay thank you and the
last one you're doing an engagement
consultation which is going to come
reported back to the council later this
year so we know what sort of form it's
going to take that's uh
8.1 which is have to engage with
residents and stakeholders to understand
the impact of one team will be agreed
with Communications lead member and
results will reported back to council
later this year running out of the year
yeah no I and so we actually had a
conversation today and we've got one
scheduled for about week's time where
we're Eng identifying how best we engage
with residents do that we've just
recently um invested in engagement HQ
which is the way we're doing our
consultation with a finance uh budget
survey it's a new platform and we're
hoping to use that as the way forward
and then we'll report back in the Q3 so
we're looking at an online sort of
Engagement we would be looking that as
the predominant way to get engaged with
members of the public these days okay
thank
you just before I bring the next Ming um
just on the back of what councelor FD
said that 8.1 that's quite quick time
turn around then um when are you
thinking of bringing that back to for
Council so even though the survey may be
taken before the end of this year it
probably won't be back until the early
part of next year to it reporting wise
just because of the timings of um
cabinet and
things so on the back of that then Greg
8.1 will need
amending yes apologies
thank you uh councelor Mrs
Belton thank you very much um it it's
pleasing to see some of the initiatives
that have been taken and um I just want
to touch on appendix one the the risk
register again positive that risks are
seem to be coming down or staying the
same um I do have one observation though
staff accommodation is seen as a risk
it's been wildly discussed that morale
could or will or is suffer uffing as a
result of location of some of the staff
um and the fact that the South Street in
particular is not deemed suitable it's
not compliant in a number of
ways is it suitable to add an extra risk
onto this risk register around
accommodation because if morale goes
down if staff leave that puts the one
team transformation at a huge risk so I
just wonder it doesn't show up anywhere
as a risk for our team and I personally
see accommodation as quite a large risk
and other members across the the council
have had similar
discussions yeah uh thank you member um
I quite like the thinking of that
actually it's not necessar necessarily
the um property itself but the risk is
that they leave which will impact on the
one team I will take that away and I'll
add that into consideration and see
where we can fit it in into that risk
register and how that works through is
that thank you thank you does that
answer all your questions yeah thank you
any other members questions coun fer
councelor Foster please I notice sorry
thank you I notice from the list of of
services and so on a number of business
cases were due for completion or review
during September quite a long list are
they all
completed apologies so a number of them
have completed there are one or two
still outstanding with some information
on but we're expecting them to come
through in the next month those ones
that are still outstanding and does that
include the reviews as well of those
that are completed but would du to be
reviewed I
[Music]
mentioned so sorry councelor Foster so
the reviews of the ones that have been
completed
already sorry um on some of them it says
business case scheduled to be reviewed
in September by
September so some if some of them have
slipped then they will be doing being
done but they should have been reviewed
in September it's because this report is
the second quarter so we're already two
months be on Beyond when that was
reported so if they're saying they were
reviewed in September they should sorry
they should have been reviewed in
September if I can pick them out is any
specific
ones sorry no it's just a general
question September date is significant
along along that big list yeah most of
them have been done in September I'd
have to check the list but because this
is quarter 2 which ended at the end of
August this is slightly out of s syncing
coming to
committee um just on the back of that
then um uh Greg um you're coming back to
overview and scrutiny in January um will
there be any um foreseen slippage or
will you see that both the reports that
were meant to be taking place in
September and October will have been
done and we will have a clear new
report yeah when I return in January
there'll be a a clear report this will
be updated um and it will be clear in
terms of what has or hasn't been done
what I can do because the way the
cabinet system works this is a a little
bit later I can give an overview an
update on the evening if anything has
slipped off since the report was meant
to be done so for example if something
was meant to be done last week and it
says it on here but it wasn't on the
evening I'll give you a verbal
update thank you uh C counselor M please
yeah just a a question for Greg I
noticed the last time chief officer
appointments committee uh in the subject
history was back in March going into
2024 I believe we've got some Chief
officers going to be retiring or moving
on so there's proactivity about the
recruitment yeah on that
area the other thing is because unlike a
normal single Council a chief officer
may find themselves if they apply for
the job doing double committees in a
month instead of singles and does this
sort of is it anticipated this might
reflect in salaries that's it really and
any problems of recruitment that's
all um all I would say on that is that
HR with the chief executive uh head of
pay service will look at the job
description and it gets evaluated across
the board and then it would be probably
in line with the Strategic director's
pay and renumeration that it is at the
moment but there is proactive work going
on at the
moment thank you does that answer your
question Council thank you Council
sparing thank you chairman um in this
Report Greg there's a number of times it
refers to uh the business case being
approved by the transformation program
board who comprises of the
transformation
board and the board here comprises of
the leader and Deputy leader of Rochford
Council and the leader and Deputy leader
of brenwood council along with the chief
executive and can I just ask as a second
how often do they meet is it is it a
continual meeting monthly or well
monthly okay thank you
monthly just going back what councel M
said I don't know if it's actually
relevant so I don't know if you'll be
able to answer this Greg but um Steve
Summers is leaving and he's employed by
Brentwood B council at the moment
correct how is the breakdown of Chief
officers or lead officers so remember
when this was first done it we were
watchwood District Council was hugely
outnumbered by brenwood B Council so
would a new lead officer be employed by
watchwood or brenwood even if he's
leaving
brenwood yeah puts me in a difficult
position because I don't know the answer
to that one I can certainly take that
back and discuss that with Emily um and
Jonathan who will be looking at that
recruitment process and then they can Le
thank
you any other questions
members no
and I've got um um a couple
myself page 6.6 when we're talking about
the support for staff um
3.17 um women we're talking about uh
mental health and uh the stress that
counselor Mrs Belton um brought up um at
the current time are there any what is
our numbers of staff on long-term
sickness and also are any of them in
senior
roles I have to admit I don't have those
figures to hand I can get them for you
uh in terms of senior members of Staff
then we can categorize what they are and
who they are and then I can report that
as well thank you um yeah I'm sorry to
Spring that one on you but it was after
um um counselor Mrs belton's question
and then on
3.18 um the employee assistance program
um I know that this is confidential
program that employes can um access but
is it possible or have you um had a uh
requested to see if there's any um sort
of themes that come
through again I can ask for that
information if there is any themes that
are coming through I think it would
probably be something that um HR would
pick up on and then refer back to CLT to
identify what other measures we can put
in place if there was a reoccurring
theme thank you it would be interesting
to know it's just again on uh counc Mrs
belton's question um if there are in
relation to the building uh where there
where they're the premises that they're
working under that sort of thing thank
you um
and then on the appendix which is in
ever such large writing
um the first
recommendation uh and it describes the
risk and it says changes in Council
leadership result in change to strategic
Direction um I can't see on here that it
actually mentions um and I don't know if
it's considered a risk that's down to um
officers and fellow members to whether
they think it is um we have also
incurred the added pressure of changing
from the cabinet system to committee has
this been included sort as as a risk
that will hold things up so to
speak I don't see that as a risk that
will potentially hold anything up I
think a nearer the time then we can
reconsider that if it's uh when we're
implementing it and if the committee
cycle is slightly
or that we can foresee that there would
be a delay but at the moment I do not
foresee it being or causing a
delay thank you councilor lambour you've
got a question
yeah the report's fine but um we're
talking about what are we talking about
150 staff or something wouldn't it have
been good to have a at least at the top
level an organizational chart within
this report so we can
see how the staff are are allocated and
also it would have been would also be
useful if we could
see how much work each individual does
for um for Brentwood and how much each
individual staff member does for
Rochford because presumably you've got a
um a uh time allocation system running
to uh to
allocate time to
people okay um so we don't have a time
allocation it's not done in that way the
job descriptions are put together when
people come into the one team that
actually it's a fair share and the job
description covers both organizations so
it's not actually put down onto the time
allocation so we wouldn't have that
information what we can do is obviously
provide the structural chart uh and
identify the different services that
fall with within each of those service
areas um and we can provide that outside
of the report Tim is pointing that he's
probably going to say there is a Time
allocation but not that I'm a
wearable try trying to be helpful on
this point um I think with the um last
time I was here flying around as soon as
I started talking um the uh senior the
senior leadership team generally are
50/50 the ones that already serving both
Council
um the um obviously if if a a service
hasn't gone through the one team process
then they're either Rood or bwood when
they come together that's when there's
an issue of how much time will they be
spending on either rodford or brenwood
um and so it's only once it's going
through and gone through the one team
process where it becomes an issue I'm I
speak from experience because I'm
working on the finance review at the
moment and brenwood has a housing
revenue account because it has a housing
stock stock which involves quite a bit
of accountancy so that needs to be
factored into the new new team so at the
moment um and it hasn't been approved by
program board yet the business case but
at the moment like for like Brentwood
Finance team will cost more than rodford
Finance team because there's more staff
needed because it's a there's more more
accounts to produce as a simple example
so we are trying to factor those things
into the into the
change thank you uh and your mic's on
any more question
councilor going on from what you said
that's what Belton said there might be
another risk with the committee system
risk to members members risk not
understanding how it will work because
I've got no idea how it's going to work
it could fall down there that might be
training and stuff like that might be
taken into mitigate the
risk so Emily you're obiously Str
strategic director who's working on the
new committee process and how that will
work with uh colleagues here at Rochford
we'll probably bring that in so that
members are aware of how the new process
will work I would hope that would be
part of the training but I will refer it
back to B Tak as one of the risks could
you would that go in there as a risk I
wouldn't part of the one scene because
it sort of no it's not really is it
because it's just watch doing that well
I wouldn't even say just because it's R
I just I wouldn't see necessarily that
being a risk of one team think is a risk
to the committee system itself and i'
probably take it that way if that's okay
members yeah I would just come in um
I've just been uh informed by officers
that training for the committee system
is in the pipeline okay otherwise I
would have suggest as a recommendation
uh councelor Foster you want to come in
thank you chairman just following
councilor lamborn's question the or
chart is on the website if anybody needs
to access
[Music]
it okay thank you uh councelor Mrs belon
thank you um just referring back to my
earlier point would it be prudent to
make a recommendation that the risk is
added to the register does that need to
go through on as a recommendation in
this report or is it something that
would be done aside from
that just so I can check is that the
risk uh Council FD was referring to or
your one my risk relating to staff
morale due to workplace and
accommodation so I've picked that up and
I will take that to the when we have our
regular meeting on one team that'll be
picked up when we review the risks at
that
point so and and that's fine Griff but
unless I'm mistaken officers can correct
me counselor Mrs belon could make that
as a recommendation if she so wishes and
if she's got a second that we can take a
vote on
it yeah I'd like to make it as a
recommendation so we've got it on record
and then hopefully you're in support
that anyway thank you I'm gonna put you
under a bit of pressure now do you want
to word your recommendation
so the recommendation is to add a a
seventh risk to the risk register
relating to staff accommodation and
Welfare that would have an impact on
morale thank you have I got to hold on a
minute go on then Tim thank you I I just
make the point I'm trying to channel
Jonathan here as head of paid service um
that there is a just a slight concern I
have that um matters related to staff
and staff welfare is an officer
responsibility and the head of paid
service the chief executive and risk
generally is managed managed by officers
and reported to members so my I suggest
you just add with word suggest to your
recommendation which might then address
the issue of any any any suggestion that
you're imposing something beyond what
members would normally be involved
with well I mean it's a recommendation
anyway so I'm only recommending that it
be added to the risk register and then
that would be for the relevant people uh
at the exec and and with Jonathan to
agree so I'm I think I'm I'm comfortable
with recommending it because it's not a
final decision yeah it is merely a
recommendation to the exact um so that
stands have you got a second thank you
councelor Mrs gadston um all those in
favor please raise your
hands
thank you um any other members
indicating so um okay before we move to
the um adding the recommendation we have
got um an amendment to this report on
page
6.8 8.1
one the last sentence on that point
8.1 that results will be reported back
to
Council in the first quarter
2024 happy with that Greg y
wonderful
councilor lambon we're just on the paper
now there's no more
questions um okay po pop your
recommendation
forward pop your mic on please following
on for my point about um a
full
um organization chart right to the very
very bottom um it's clear from the work
I've been doing and others have done
that there are lots of vacancies as well
and and the people in um Rochford are
not getting the resources they require
so I would like a risk put in that the
um allocation of workload between um
Brentwood and rwood needs to be
monitored so that we can monitor the
work risk between the two councils and
also we can see where the specific um
where the specific uh vacancies arise
where there are
shortfalls Council lambor that's not so
much of um a risk so therefore wouldn't
be a recommendation are you saying you
would like to see more detail in the
forthcoming report to show if there's
vacancies and areas and and where the
work is has been done and allocated is
that possible Greg the the work done and
allocated is down to the management side
of things within the authority so it's a
bit difficult to kind of drill down that
because where the organizations aren't
set up in that way anyway I think what
we can do is identify where the
resources are in the structure which we
said we could do in terms of the numbers
of Staff um in terms of sickness those
figures can also be provided um but
generally the other stuff which is about
how work is allocated is down to the
manager we can also report on vacancies
so you can see where they are that's not
an issue we have that information
already it wouldn't necessarily be in my
report or this report it' probably be in
performance
monitoring yeah I'll be honest Council
ambor this is more of a strategic
overview as oppos opposed to
operational but if the officers can um
feedback that information for us as Greg
has offered I would have thought part of
the Strategic overview would be to know
where the work was being done and who
was who they were doing it
for no I'm thank you again I'll follow
my colleague Tim that is more of an
operational thing that is down to the
managers to identify I think especially
when it comes into probably the one team
as Tim's alluded to that's where kind of
the separation of work and where one
Authority may be doing more than the
other that is divided by the cost and
who pays what for it but it still
wouldn't be going down to as far as
looking at worksheets and timings and
things yes councilor um it's just that I
come from a uh Finance background and
consultancy background and every time we
did a bit of work we we we had to put a
code against it to show who we were
working for how much time we put on it
and whatever and I can't
see how Rochford District Council has
walked into an into an arrangement where
it doesn't monitor that um allocation of
time um I think um Greg will say um time
and budgets are monitored that is just
that it's more of an operational role
with the managers and this is more of a
strategic overview I don't know if Greg
or Tim want to come back and comment any
more on
that thanks chair um I'm trying to
capture the essence of of council lorn's
issue I think the way that Senior
Management handle it as well as I would
suggest members is to monitor whether or
not something's done and how well it's
done not how it's done um so it's not so
it's not so much workload that is at
Play It's whether or not people are
doing the job um just as I would say to
my head of Finance at Rochford why
haven't you done the treasury management
report because your equivalent number of
rwood has done it um that is the same
sort of challenge that you could put to
offices about outputs and what's
actually delivered um and as as I said
as regards allocation of time so that
there's a fair apportionment of cost we
are picking that up as each one team of
you is is conducted and
completed
thank you um councelor Mr Mill um yeah
just a question for Tim would it be fair
to say in light of the fact that there's
been a continuity of
accountancy as we've gone into the
transformation program but with savings
actually
highlighted that in fact if we were
worried about all that that wouldn't be
the case would it if we weren't
monitoring it that way because we seem
to have a continuity of accounts and
balance sheets but we also have a saving
so is that a good observation as
evidence of it in general because the
one team objectives were to increase
resilience and to deliver deliver
efficiency savings so as's a general
statement that is true any one
particular review may not result in a
saving for one or other of the councils
depending on how the configuration of
the of the new team but as a general
statement that would be true
yes okay and keeping it to the report
and talking to the report one more
member councelor FD um councelor lambor
might be a little bit CAU before the hor
because a lot of this report says
business place to be approved and until
it's approved we don't know how many
people we're going to need in each part
of the council
so I think when the business cases get
approved it will come back to this
committee or for Council and then we
know
more okay members we we have got on the
table um
a this report is for noting and also
recommendation so first of all members
is the report
noted thank you
members and my Veronica swiftly writes
down the recommendation that she's going
to pass to
me okay and the recommendation members
to add a
further seventh risk to the risk
register relating to staff accommodation
and Welfare that would Impact Staff
Morel um all those in favor
members that's unanimous thank you
members agenda
item Jo sorry would it be possible to
add an
amendment
it's been voted
on uh members agenda item seven treasury
management quarterly review
2023-24 members I will now invite the
council's director of resources Tim
Willis to introduce this
report thank you chair um this is the
first treasury management report of the
financial year we have an extra one um
to produce from now on in accordance
with the new or revised Treasury and
Prudential rules um which are National
rules um the report highlights
relatively high but Falling inflation
and the same for interest rates going
forwards um The High um relative level
of interest rates helps Investments and
the latest rates um being earned are
around
5% um we are forecasting a surplus
against budget for this year of 457,000
,000 so we'll exceed our budget uh
income by 457,000 which has been built
into the budget monitoring report that
went to the executive on the 21st of
September the council has no borrowing
um current borrowing would cost in
excess of
5% um one other thing i' I'd mention uh
tonight is that I've contacted our
treasury management advis advisors
called link link group um to arrange a
training session on Treasury management
for members so I'll let all members know
when that date is and try and make the
date suitable suitable time probably do
it jointly with brenwood as well because
it's bit of a specialist
subject happy to answer any
questions members uh councilor
FD sorry chairman uh just couple
Investments and
balances so it takes says it takes an an
um an average level of funds of 20.8
million what actually is what part of
that is actually ours CU I know we
collect funds from other people we
probably invest them invest them before
we have to pay them to essics and
whatever so what actually do we actually
have which is actually our money
invested I he was going to ask you two
questions
but um the that as it says it's the
average level of funds it does fluctuate
quite significantly even on a day-to-day
basis um by millions um when we pay the
payroll for example that's a big chunk
and if there's a big Capital project
with a big contract payment that could
be a large amount um it so it does
fluctuate quite a lot and and the main
fluctuations tend to be around when we
invest money it's only relatively short
term so it might be a matter of three
months and so then when um once we come
to the end of that three months we
suddenly get the influx of 5 million
back and then we put it out again so on
any one day it fluctuates quite
significantly the average for the
quarter is 20 million which is not
untypical of the sort of amount of cash
that we're holding at the
moment thank you Tim I couldn't have
answered councelor fd's question any
better myself have you got a question so
obstated really well around the actual
question was how much that money is
actually ours because I remember counsil
a couple years ago when we was talking
about funds what funds we had he took
that 2 something million pound and
thought that was what we actually had as
a council it's not what we got as a
council is what we collect for other
people we invest until we pay pay them
out yeah it's it's I try and compare
this with personal savings so if you if
you have a personal savings account and
you have some money stashed away that
you can use for specific purpose or for
R rainy day you've really got that cash
and you know you've got that cash but if
you You' got a current bank account and
there's money flowing in and out all the
time at any one time it might be really
big because you've just been paid for
example and the rent hasn't gone out and
you think oh I've got loads of money I
can spend it and you haven't and I think
that's the point you're making that's
what this 20 million is it's like a
current account figure it's cash it's
not our reserves our reserves are what
you would see on the balance sheet on um
the outturn report and on on the budget
reports which are the last last count of
about 12 million
that was while after thank
you uh thank you chairman um yeah this
is probably a very simplistic question
from a simple person um it's great that
we're obviously making uh more money on
our investments than we had budgeted for
457,000 above budget um there's a
tradeoff of course with increased costs
due to inflation is this not the report
to
mention how the balance sheet
effectively uh plays out with those
inflationary costs taken into
account yes it's a it's a fair point
that um the difficulty with the holding
cash in inflationary times
is inflation's whatever six 7% now and
the best we can ear is 5% on our on our
investment and it sounds great and it
looks good in budget terms but actually
inflation is eating away at the value
all the time um that is an issue um one
of the reasons why there is a sizable
amount of cash available in rushford's
accounts is um because we know that
there's Capital program which is the big
item to spend that um the council's
committed to at the moment it's yet to
have a revised Capital program and that
means that we retain enough cash in
order to cover those costs because we
don't borrow and it's not inflation has
the negative effect not only of eating
away at the value of the cash that we're
holding but if we do eventually have
some big spending in the future it will
be at inflated prices so again it's it's
a double double effect of inflation
that's hitting us I'm I'm not advocating
we spend every penny we've got now
because it's more efficient but it is
just a consequence and all we can do is
mitigate that by investing it at as good
a rate as we can whilst ensuring that
we've got liquidity and uh and it's at
low risk yeah thank you for that I I
just can't see anything in the report
about uh inflationary pressures but I
guess it's not a report to show that
balance it's uh it's a treasury report
how we invest the money and and this is
bonus but uh the the inflationary
pressures are presume reported somewhere
else there is reference inflation in the
report I'm just looking at three but
it's not
Quantified there's some references to
inflation in in the economic update in
section three um but it's a very macro
analysis it doesn't apply the
consequences of the predictions on
inflation to Rochford situation um but
the if youve if if you have inflation
and you're holding
cash the the solution is spend your
cash that's not necessarily A wise
course of action because really what
you're doing is coming back to council
F's Point using up the reserves and once
they used up you've lost them so if you
spend them on something it's going to
earn you a return that can beat
inflation great but there's not many of
those sorts of Investments out there
yeah I guess I guess my point is that
obviously we we have um costs we have a
procurement uh side and their costs are
increasing but it's not it's not
Quantified anywhere in this report it's
for another report I
guess councelor Mrs
gon and Tim um
2.5.1 um in the table below um the first
um handles and banken um it's a free
month fixed together but the interest
rate is only
4.2 and the instant accounts are higher
is that normally reverse of how it
normally is with I just wonder if you
could
explain a good de um yes in general
notice accounts offer higher interest
rate as a general principle um it
doesn't always apply but the main reason
this has happened is because the handles
Bank and investment was taken out at a
point when interest rates were what they
were and then another moment in time we
took money out with Deutsche Bank and it
was even though it was instant it was at
higher rate of interest just because of
the fluctuating rates of Interest which
do vary know minute by minute never mind
day by
day can I just come back and say so once
that three month am I um understanding
that once that three months fixed has
come to an end that you'll then move
that into well for 30th of June so would
that then be reassessed as to going into
a different three Monon fixed account
with a higher rate is that something
that they'll be moving the money
around um yes that's that's correct in
fact I uh was requested to approve a
money market transaction just today and
I'm just um trying to see if I can
find how much it was but uh I can't
instantly find it I'm afraid but it was
it was uh6 million
pounds um 3 million into abidine money
markets um of the Six Million the other
the other three million still to be
allocated at at 5. 233% so these things
are happening all the time so yes as
soon as it it comes to maturity it will
be reinvested yeah thank you for
clarifying that team Council
lambor yeah on page 7.4 on the capital
expenditure table I noticed that um
there's a prediction of our Capital
reserves going down by 1.4 million is
that money allocated what what are we
spending that on is that is that the
penalty Clauses in the um G ADP
or yeah um that's not talking to the
paper councilor lambon
um
Council okay why why has our capital
reserve gone
down I can answer that question um so
this table shows the what we originally
assumed for the capital program 4.87
million spend and so we needed to
finance all of that from all those
different sources and then what it was
saying is we're only going to spend 3.76
to we're now forecasting so we're over a
million pound we think of slippage we're
not going to spend all the capital
program that we thought we were going to
spend so that
soed on expenditure for the year is down
by 1.1 million so that means that we
don't have to finance so much capital
expenditure and the and the and the one
that one of the one one of the ones
that's changed significantly is the
Capital Finance Reserve we don't need to
draw upon so much of the Capital Finance
Reserve if we don't end up spending as
much as we thought we were going to
spend at the start of the
year does that help that's a good thing
yes
wonderful sorry I will I um
2.9.1 um Capital financing requirement
what is
that the capital financing requirement
is the the official definition is the
unfinanced element of capital spending
unfinanced meaning it's not from
external Grant it's not from reserves
and it's not from Capital receipts so
the implication being normally the CFR
Capital financing Reserve is your
external borrowing
but um rodford doesn't have any external
borrowing so um I've actually posed this
question of link group our treasury
management advisors because this is a
historic thing it's been there for years
um and I've been waiting for somebody to
ask me that question at every treasury
management report that I've presented so
far um it I can only conclude that it
was internal borrowing so that's the
opposite of external borrowing we didn't
borrow from somebody else we borrowed
from ourselves meaning if we've got a
lot of cash then effectively we're just
using our cash to to give it to
ourselves to fund something that cost
770,000
77,000 but I'm having that um
historically looked at to bottom out
what that's specifically related to
because I'd be curious as to why we
didn't just fund it from reserves or
fund it from some other source at that
historic moment where we incurred
$777,000 worth of capital expenditure so
I can respond to council FD and the rest
of the committee once I've got
definitive answer on that but that's as
much of an answer as I can give right
now thank you Tim and I think youve made
councilor F's not um councilor cross
please thank you chairman uh just a
quick question to Tim uh s16 section 106
income um where does that come from how
is that uh
Quantified and how can it be increased
more uh
effectively um so this is in um in
paragraph 2.8 on page 7.4 yeah um yeah
the section 106 income is um related to
if there's a development in the in the
district the the de developer will pay a
certain sum um in order to get planning
permission which relates to typically
traditionally infrastructure that needs
to be enhanced but it's often to do with
things like play spaces and and such
like um and the way to increase section
106 income in general is to approve more
planning applications which requires
people wanting to build in in the
district um it's uh
there are other options other than
section 106 but that's the main means by
which you can monetize as a council
planning applications planning approvals
um and this will just be the amount that
is being allocated to this year's
Capital program and is rein fenced
there'll be a capital project or
projects worth we budgeted for 70,000
and we think it will be 80,000 for the
year now um they will relate to specific
projects which are section 106 funded
and we can't use that section 106
funding for anything other than those
projects is being used for that's not to
say there's all that all that there is
that's the only section 106 funding is
often section 106 held sometimes for
years before it's used because the
development agreements sometimes allow
for years before you need to actually
incur the expenditure and then claim the
funding from the developer um but that's
the amount that we're due to allocate
this financial year thanks for that Tim
anecdotally I've heard that section 106
six Finance has been you know there's
been missed opportunities to recover it
uh is is it down to officers to to
effectively put in a claim for it or is
it uh um Council cross that that might
be outside of um this report if I'm
honest with you but you can take that
app with um the officers around section
106 um they will be able to give you a
whole breakdown of what is available as
Tim explained it will will be ear marked
so sometimes the developer will hold on
to it until you've got a project coming
forward so is quite useful to know so
perhaps officers could make sure that
that reports sent over to counselor
cross thank you uh councelor Mrs gadston
Tim going back to the 777
figure could I just ask
um when you report back to us whether
this figure
um whether there is any outstanding
balance where originally where it's come
from whether there's any outstanding
balance and what it was spent on if it
was spent and if it was an
asset how relevant is that figure in
terms of any depreciation of an asset do
you see what I mean where is it being
balanced as to what we've spent it on
and if it's an asset its value now and
as that loan if it was a loan has it
been completely paid
paid um I'll provide what information I
can it might be really old might go
about many years so it might be there
might be limited information and and
quite often with these with with funding
of the capital program and treasury
management it's difficult to identify a
specific asset against a particular loan
and this isn't an external loan but in
terms of a specific loan sometimes
funding is just pulled so there'll be a
whole program to deliver and then
there'll be a whole program to finance
and that and all the financing pot will
be put together and then trying to
allocate well which bit of Finance
relates to which capital project isn't
always that straightforward so I can't
be sure I'll be able to identify an
asset against the liability if indeed it
is a true liability that we have of
770,000
Tim we get to understand whether that
figure should be continued carry forward
or whether it should be written off yes
that's one of my objectives by
Consulting link if if
it's if it's not
real and we can take action to remove it
I would rather have a clean zero CFR
rather than having this continued on if
it if it costs us
$777,000 to remove it then I might not
want to remove it but if it's just
making a decision to do so then I would
be Keen to encourage members to approve
such a decision
thank you Tim and we've got one more
question for you uh councelor Foster
please thank you chairman scry two
points Council cross's uh comments s16
has reminded me that we did agree some
time ago that there will be a quarterly
update report on s106 um money which I
haven't seen for quite a long time uh
second point is I'm being a bit flippant
here I hope this doesn't lead to a
recommendation to encourage Builders to
build more homes
um I I can answer um your question there
uh councelor Foster we were just talking
about that there is a report that goes
in front of I think it was the planning
policy so that will be circulated to all
members after um Council cross question
now if if I may I am on that and we
haven't emphasize we haven't seen it for
a very long time yeah and that isn't for
this meeting so officers have made a
note of that thank you councelor Foster
any more members question questions on
the paper that's in front of
you no thank you um then we have the um
one recommendation to note the contents
of the treasury management quarter one
report um is that noted members thank
you
members uh thanks to our officers uh Tim
and Greg and if you would like to excuse
yourselves you're most welcome to do
[Music]
so
members agenda item eight it is the
appointment of a working group to review
the council's outside bodies and
Partnerships so um members um I would
like to ask members to volunteer to join
this working group as per the scoping
document which was agreed at the meeting
on the 13th of September members could I
have um hands for anybody willing to do
this councel Mrs belon if I may I'm not
volunteering but I'd like to put forward
counselors woodon and wal if there's
space for them because of their
understanding of outside bodies consider
themselves on the
list any other members like to put their
names forward councelor lambor thank you
very much councelor PA Mrs Paige sorry
thank you that's four um that should
suffice would you like myself on there
or the chair numers is always better
chairman okay I'll go on there
then thank you members that was easily
down wasn't
there people will make sure they're here
next time w't
they um agenda item nine the key
decisions document um members this is
the same document that you saw last
meeting so unless there's any questions
councelor FY sorry right the key
decision of uh suspension of parking
charges on Saturday before
Christmas
um recommend this a shame that Phoebe is
not here to answer these questions is
churn car park Churn it says on here the
charging of the car park may be
perceived as having a negative impact on
the High Street trades at Key period of
the year but it could also have
a positive impact
regarding churn or Vehicles so I'd like
to maybe recommend that there's a survey
of cars and vans that are just dumped in
the car
park over the weekend which aren't
actually encouraging people to shop and
people will go somewhere
else I don't know if you can on that I'm
not
sure that will be taken back to the
office councilor FD any more comments on
the key decision
documents councelor Foster thank you
chairman just probably the same question
as I asked on the earlier report the
decisions that were due to be made in
September have they been
made Sonia would just advise on this one
so the Environmental Health Service Plan
uh went to Executive in in in September
and was approved and similarly the
modern slavery act 2015 uh key decision
went to Executive in September and was
approved um that's the
two thank you um thank you councelor
Foster um so that's um the key decision
document no other show of hands um
agenda item 10 the work
plan members again you've got this in
front of
you um our next meeting in December is
quite a fall
meeting um
January um we could bring forward one of
the three items that need to be
scheduled um it's got 2425 on there so
yeah is that correct that date because I
thought it's was for this work
plan
234 fine um so members any suggestions
for which one of those three we could
slot in in January who will councelor
Mrs belum um I'd like to see the outcome
of the council's planning service review
if possible because that's quite a
prudent one that members have have asked
about multiple times so if we could see
it sooner I think that would be helpful
all in agreement that one lovely thank
you members thank you and then we've got
uh February which one of the remaining
two would you like to bring forward for
February should I suggest the pre-
scrutiny of local cycling walking
infrastructure
plan Sonia will that be available in
time for then do you feel I'll have to
go back to uh to the officer and uh and
ask that you know to be to be brought
forward if there if there's a problem
then I will okay if if there is a
problem then if that could come forward
in March um if not in March will be the
review of Engagement with stakeholders
and
residents thank you members um anybody
sorry and would it be prudent that we in
January actually review the work plan
just to make sure that it's achieving
what we want to achieve in case we want
to bring anything different
at that point with the last three months
of it to go um we usually do um add
those for the fourth coming Municipal
year and if there are items that you
would like to bring forward to the work
plan before then then just bring those
forward at this meeting or through the
offices so we can do that at any point
at any point as long as we can um
accomplish that amount of work in that
time I'm sure we can with your effective
chairing
on that note members um I will close the
meeting at 8:30 thank you very much for
your
attendance